Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are living the advent of neural
network-based image generation algorithms.
What you see here is some super high quality
results from a technique developed by scientists
at NVIDIA called StyleGAN2.
Right, all of these were generated by a learning
algorithm.
And, while generating images of this quality
is a great achievement, but if we have an
artistic vision, we wonder, can we bend these
images to our will?
Can we control them?
Well, kind of, and one of the methods that
enables us to do that is called image interpolation.
This means that we have a reference image
for style, and a target image, and with this,
we can morph one human face into another.
This is sufficient for some use cases, however,
if we are looking for more elaborate edits,
we hit a wall.
Now it’s good that we already know what
StyleGAN is, because this new work builds
on top of that, and shows exceptional image
editing and interpolation abilities.
Let’s start with the image editing part!
With this new work, we can give anyone glasses,
and a smile, or even better, transform them
into a variant of the Mona Lisa.
Beautiful.
The authors of the paper call this process
semantic diffusion.
Now, let’s have a closer look at the expression
and pose change possibilities.
I really like that we have fine-grained control
over these parameters, and what’s even better,
we don’t just have a start and endpoint,
but all the intermediate images make sense,
and can stand on their own.
This is great for pose and expression because
we can control how big of a smile we are looking
for, or even better, we can adjust the age
of the test subject with remarkable granularity.
Let’s go all out!
I like how Mr. Cumberbatch looks nearly the
same as a baby, we might have a new mathematical
definition for baby face right there, and
apparently Mr. DiCaprio scores a bit lower
on that.
And I would say that both results are quite
credible!
Very cool!
And now, onto image interpolation.
What does this new work bring to the table
in this area?
Previous techniques are also pretty good at
morphing…until we take a closer look at
them.
Let’s continue our journey with three interpolation
examples, with increasing difficulty.
Let’s see the easy one first.
I was looking for morphing example with long
hair, you will see why right away.
This is how the older method did.
Uh-oh.
One more time.
Do you see what I see?
If I stop the process here, you see that this
is an intermediate image that doesn’t make
sense.
The hair over the forehead just suddenly vanishes
into the ether.
Let’s see how the new method deals with
this issue!
Wow, much cleaner, and I can stop nearly anywhere
and leave the process with a usable image.
Easy example, checkmark.
Now let’s see an intermediate-level example!
Let’s go from an old black and white Einstein
photo to a recent picture with colors and
stop the process at different points, and…yes,
I prefer the picture created with the new
technique close to every single time!
Do you agree?
Let me know in the comments below!
Intermediate example, checkmark.
And now, onwards to the let’s hardest, nastiest
example.
This is going to sound impossible, but we
are going to transform the Eiffel Tower into
the Tower Bridge.
Yes, that sounds pretty much impossible.
So let’s see how a conventional interpolation
technique did here.
Well…that’s not good.
I would argue that nearly none of the images
showcased here would be believable if we stopped
the process and took them out.
And let’s see the new method.
Hmm, that makes sense, we start with one tower,
then, two towers grow from the ground, and…look!
Wow!
The bridge slowly appears between them.
That was incredible.
While we look at some more results, what really
happened here?
At the risk of simplifying the contribution
of this new paper, we can say that during
interpolation, it ensures that we remain within
the same domain for the intermediate images.
Intuitively, as a result, we get less nonsense
in the outputs, and can pull off morphing
not only between human faces, but even go
from a black and white photo to a colored
one, and what’s more, it can even deal with
completely different building types.
Or, you know, just transform people into Mona
Lisa variants.
Absolutely amazing.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!